[Laughter]
wow
john this is unbelievable
i knew that you were gonna do something
my job what's unbelievable jimmy
he's finally letting us see him or that
his costume for a big budget dc
blockbuster is that
shall we say daring hello everyone
carlos here
no spoilers for this nerd alert but we
are going to touch on the sensitive
subject
of john cena's very comics accurate
costume in the suicide squad so
for all you john cena fans if you want
some
go get some
wait i love it this is peacemaker
this is uh the first actual interview
that peacemaker has ever done and i
wanted to bestow it upon you
and uh i just it's a really special
occasion so thanks for having me man
i really i love being there in person
but because we're miles away i wanted to
i want peacemaker to show i love this
wait i have so many questions because
this is
we talked last time you were here you
were a first guest in studio by the way
thank you for doing that
uh and uh and you you said you're doing
a spin-off series
uh for peacemaker and here you are as
are you on set
yeah so this is actually peacemaker's
house
and in on the contrary peacemaker is
like a a polar opposite of bruce wayne
where bruce wayne would be a billionaire
with a bat cave
i live in a single wide and this
is my outfit so and that's a bit of an
interesting story
and a bit of a bit of a new tale okay so
if you're not clear on who peacemaker is
he's in john's own words the douchey
captain america
who's set to feature in james gunn's
upcoming sequel to suicide squad
entitled
the suicide squad and if you're not
clear on who john cena is well
are we even friends be like a douchey
captain america
the guy who believes in peace at any
cost
no matter how many people he needs to
kill along the way
okay i got it the character's real name
is christopher smith and that helmet he
wears is capable of emitting ultrasonic
frequencies that can overwhelm the
senses of anyone in range
which is an ability set that sounds
eerily familiar
we've already seen from another clip
released in warner brothers all
streaming ad
that john will face off with idris alba
in the film
no one likes to show off unless what
they're showing off is dope as [ __ ] but
what john doesn't know
is that he's already facing off with the
48 year old actor in our interviews
okay so this all started when it's told
keisha shante that he's pretty sure
his suicide squad suit is the best
i have uh essentially i think arguably
one of the coolest
um superhero suits you know i'm saying
arguably
you know we went to a lot of james gunn
he was incredible director went to a lot
of time to make a
a design that we think is going to be
you know great to watch and
um super entertaining to see me use so
uh yeah you know i i didn't bring i
didn't strip down in that in that film
and when morgan hoffman followed up with
idris and john's co-star joel kidman
the actor confirmed idris's claims and
sorry john
boasted that cena's costume is the worst
we just interviewed your suicide squad
co-star idris alba he said he has the
best suit
in the film do you agree with that or do
you think yours is a bit better
um he definitely has a better suit than
me that's for damn sure
um yeah he's got a pretty
the suit is pretty good i gotta say it's
pretty good
it's pretty good i mean
john cena's is the most ridiculous um
idris might have the best yeah that
might be true actually
that's what you get when you're going
against a guy that's a literal shark
so i mean clearly his best now obviously
john has yet to respond to this but he
did tell jimmy fallon about the hardest
stunt
he had to do on set that right there is
the face of defeat
that is me eating 37th of 40 empanadas
we had to do this one big take because
the
horribly beautiful corrupted mind of
james gunn uh operates in so many
intricate pieces and he wanted this
big giant take where i thought it'd be
cool to like oh it'd be funny to eat the
whole empanada
bro the guy catches it it's gonna be
great
everybody's gonna think it's awesome i
had to do it 40 times
and nearly ate myself sick and you can
tell by that picture i was not having a
good day that was my most difficult
stunt in the suicide squad look at him
risking his gastrointestinal health for
art that's what a hero looks like people
now while his co-stars might be having a
bit of fun with how his character looks
it seems like jon's going to be getting
the last laugh
after all peacemaker is getting his own
spin-off series on hbo max
so we'll maybe get to see more of this
alright so based on what you've seen who
has the best suit in the suicide squad
let me know in the comments below
and i'll see you on friday for my recap
of episode 5 of wand division we have
recaps of every episode up until this
point if you don't want to miss that
like subscribe all the good things
alright see ya